[موسيقى]
بعد تسعه محطات حول المملكه وجوله
افتراضيه وصل اكثر من 40 عرض و 54 موهبه
للمنافسه الى نهائيات الرحله الابداعيه
اللي قامت بها اكاديميه ام بي سي بالشراكه
مع الهيئه العامه للترفيه حيث اختتمت
الرحله الابداعيه نصف النهائي بتاهل
المواهب المتميزه اللي راح تلتقي في
النهائيات لتتنافس على المركز الاول
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذول اللي اخترناهم اليوم راح يتنافسوا مع
بعض في النصف النهائي هيتقابلوا مع بعض كل
اللي اخترناهم يعني خمسه من هنا 10 من هنا
هيتقابلوا مع بعض وناخذ منهم متصفه يعني
احنا هالمره نقول مو الله يعينهم الله
يعيننا نحن لانهم هم كلهم متميزين ففي
الاختيار راح يكون اختيار صعب جدا
[موسيقى]
بشكل ايجابي طبعا
وكلهم بلا استثناء همم بسيطه اللي كانت في
يدهم مره حلو وشيء وبدرك بدايه
جدا جدا
يا اهلا وسهلا فيكم اليوم احنا موجودين في
الرياض في نصف النهائيات في الرحله
الابداعيه
اشوفها صراحه من مواهب ما شاء الله يعني
في انتقاء عالي الجوده من جميع انحاء
المملكه فخوره شبابنا فخوره بناتنا اليوم
بمختلف الاعمار ما شاء الله في منافسه
شرسه همم وصولهم لهذه المرحله
على فكره فلازم نتعب انفسنا في في بادره
موهبه داخليه وفي شغب شايفتها في جميع
المواهب اللي همم التقيت فيها همم محتاجين
نطور اكثر ونشتغل ونشد الهمه فالكم
التوفيق يا رب
صراحه تجربه
خياليه
كانت رائعه اليوم اليوم شفنا ااا سته فئات
بصراحه الفئات هذه انا قريبه من قلبي لان
فيها تمثيل وفيها اخراج وفيها كتابه
والكتابه كانت
يعني تفاجات مع المواهب وتحمست ان مو بس
الفائزين بيكون عندهم فرص كل الناس بتكون
عندهم فرص لانهم من جد الكتاب هو شيء هي
البذره البني عينيها كل العمل و لازم تكون
صالحه ولازم نعطي فرصه اكثر ومتحمسه اشوف
شو ممكن يسووا مشاريعنا الجايه وبالتوفيق
لك لحد
[موسيقى]